bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france parlons tout d'abord
de ces sanctions on l'a dit une liste de
sanctions ciblées à l'encontre de
membres clés du gouvernement en
d'alexandre loukachenko également des
entreprises
est ce que vous en savez plus bonjour
non pour l'instant il est plus
d'informations concrètes qui ont été
diffusées dans les médias effectivement
la porte parole de la maison blanche a
annoncé que des sanctions a ciblé
allaient être prises en discussion avec
les à l'union européenne comme 3
certains membres dirigeants en
biélorussie ce qui est plus intéressant
je trouve à ce sont les sanctions qui
sont réactivées par les états unis à
l'encontre à 2,9 grandes entreprises un
biélorusse
l'intérêt de ces sanctions étant de
d'impact et l'économie biélorusse
puisque l'économie biélorusse
comme tous les autres pays s'est
globalisée rentrer dans la globalisation
allez donc beaucoup plus fragile et
beaucoup plus atteignable et c'est
effectivement là dessus que les états
unis veulent taper ce sont donc des
sanctions qui vont aussi toucher la
population à belo russe tout à fait
puisque s'il y a des difficultés à
économique il va y avoir des difficultés
sociales et l'intérêt est donc de
montrer de faire sortir une année
contentement populaire contre
loukachenko puisque pour l'instant
malgré tout le financement des
manifestations en biélorussie tous les
avis
alors nous avons une petite interruption
est ce que votre micro fonctionne
toujours
bon bah là nous avons une petite coupure
on va enchaîner sur une autre question
je vous en prie washington qui parle
aussi d'un affront direct normes
internationales alors avec cette
escalade des tensions
jusqu'où cela peut aller selon vous cela
peut aller aussi loin que la volonté
politique des états unis ne veulent
puisque la question des pages védique la
question est politique en l'occurrence
la biélorussie a diffusé la
communication entre les contrôleurs du
ciel et le pilote il n'y a eu aucune
menace là
pour faire atterrir l'avion il a sa peau
une explication selon laquelle un des
messages ont été envoyés dans différents
aéroports disant que l'avion était miné
après le pilote de lui même a accepté de
poser l'avion donc sur le plan juridique
il n'y a strictement rien à redire
l'avion et au su des têt dans l'espace
un territoriale dello russo la
biélorussie a réagi tout à fait
normalement la question est politique
c'est à les etats-unis ont besoin
d'attaquer la biélorussie comme ils ont
besoin d'attaquer la russie et ils ne
peuvent pas se permettre de laisser ce
territoire hors contrôle
et puisque les états la russie a très
justement dit qu'elle ne voulait pas
participer à l' enquête internationale
pour la simple et bonne raison que c'est
une affaire interne d'autant plus qu'il
est surprenant dans ce cas là d'abord à
dire qui est accusé et ensuite de mettre
en place une enquête internationale qui
ne pourra absolument pas du tout être
objectif puisqu'elle doit simplement
conforter ce qui a été dit n'oublions
pas par ailleurs que maiden vient de
déposer le projet de budget américain
qui lui aussi est extrêmement
significative surtout avant la rencontre
avec poutine
surtout dans le cadre la biélorussie
puisque plus de 800 milliards de dollars
sont prévus pour diffuser les intérêts
américains a en chine en russie et en
iran plus de 600 millions de dollars
sont adressés à l'europe pour l'aider à
faire repousser l'attitude agressive de
la russie et plus de 200 milliards
millions pardon de dollars envoyés à
l'ukraine pour directement combattre
entre guillemets l'agression russe
donc on ne peut pas dire que ce soit une
position de conciliation une dernière
question karine bcgo le fco le président
russe a rencontré alexandre loukachenko
à sotchi en quoi ce soutien de moscou à
la biélorussie est il déterminant est
utile pour minsk à deux points tout
d'abord puisque
à l'école et la russie peut aider
économiquement la biélorussie et comme
elle le fait et comme il est prévu
qu'elle le fasse
selon ce qui a été annoncé mais
également politiquement puisque la
biélorussie est un petit pays qui est
certes un pays qui a quand même une
force intérieure véritable
administration à véritable état est donc
une véritable armée mais qui ne peut pas
non plus seule lutte est difficilement
seule lutte et commentera les puissances
de l'otan qui sont en face d'elle donc
le fait de savoir que la russie et
derrière la biélorussie bloque toute
possibilité de coup d'état
extérieure directe en biélorussie où
toute idée d' agression militaire
déguisé avec des groupes terroristes ou
d'autres mécanismes comme on a pu le
voir dans d'autres pays merci beaucoup
pour votre éclairage karine déchets a
goal of co je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou merci